the process of building self-confidence
is actually very easy believe it or not
if you're an athlete for example you're
a 70-degree athlete and you start
training all the time with 85 and 90
degrees your identity through osmosis
goes up so proving your family wrong or
right is the symptom of the same disease
which is you are still obsessed with
what other people are thinking about you
and not doing things that make you happy
that enrich you once or get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best EDI let and how to develop
unwavering confidence mentor me ed okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
keep the promises you make to yourself
I'd be getting ass lately about the
struggles people are going through with
self-doubt not believing in themselves
negative thoughts about themselves and I
believe the solution to self-doubt is to
build something bigger than that doubt
which is to build our self-confidence
and one thing to know about the fact
that you doubt yourself is one I
struggle with it as well one of the
reasons I've had to go learn to build
all these tools for myself is because in
my life my baseball career my academic
career my business career my speaking
career I've been riddled with self-doubt
that creeps up all the time in Our Lives
am i enough am I good enough you weren't
born doubting you weren't born
discouraged you weren't born thinking
negative things about yourself
those were thoughts that were placed in
you and given to you by an external
source at some time in your life
it could even be our parents don't do
that be quiet
sit down be a good boy be a good girl
maybe it was criticism you received as a
as a little one that you may not even
remember to this day the process of
building self-confidence is actually
very easy believe it or not self
confidence is self Trust so if
confidence is building a reputation with
yourself that you keep your word to you
that you keep the promises you make to
you when I meet somebody who has a ton
of self-confidence I don't look at that
as somebody with a big ego there's a
difference somebody with self-confidence
has a reputation with themselves and I
do the things I say I'm going to do
that's where self confidence comes from
when I meet someone who's not self
confident I know this is someone who has
consistently made promises to themselves
they've not kept they've started a diet
and done it for a while but not kept it
they've made a commitment in goals to go
make a certain amount of money in
business and they started down the road
but then they didn't deliver on it long
term to get up at a certain time of the
morning
and then they don't do it and so they
have a process and a habit in their life
more often than not of not keeping the
promises they don't make to other people
they don't keep the promises they make
to them sell
and so the cool thing is self-confidence
is an internal game you do not need
external accolades external admiration
in order to build self-confidence you
don't need any of those external forces
it's all done internally you control
this and you control this by beginning
today to keep the promises you make to
yourself and you have to stack the deck
in your favor stack the game so you win
it's not good enough just to keep the
promises you make to yourself you must
acknowledge it when you do it to you to
give yourself credit to create
confidence momentum is what I call it so
whether that's setting the deck where
you're gonna get up a little bit earlier
you're gonna make a certain amount of
phone calls you this is a certain amount
of appointments you're gonna eat a
certain amount of calories and your
fitness you're gonna spend a certain
amount of time with your children or
your parents and you begin to do these
things you say you're going to be say
simple things like I'm gonna lay out my
clothes the night before I go to bed
every night before I go to sleep so when
I wake up that decisions made for me and
believe it or not the fact that you just
do something that simple that you then
deliver on begins to build confidence
you say I'm gonna stretch in the morning
when I get up and you do it all of a
sudden I'm not gonna check my phone for
thirty minutes all these habits I teach
when you just begin to do the things you
tell yourself you're going to do you
begin to build self confidence which is
this reputation with yourself so ask
yourself a question right now what is
one thing right now one promise I can
make to myself that I'm going to begin
to keep starting this minute and begin
to do it a Kabhi Gham how often I'm
gonna pick up a book and read it but you
begin to stack things you commit to do
and then you deliver on them and you
acknowledge them to yourself you're in
the process of building self-confidence
why is that so important of all the
athletes I coach well my athletes are
performing at their peak level they're
their highest self confidence level in
fact I love when I watch some of the
athletes I coach get interviewed and
they kind of do this aw shucks humble
routine in their approach game
interviews yeah you know just part of
the team you know I got a lot I could
have done a lot better today but inside
I know these people are incredibly
self-confident people any of you
athletes listening this you know that's
the great athletes you know have
incredible amounts of self-confidence
you have to believe in you when it's a
battle when you're
hitter against a pitcher when you're a
quarterback against a defense or you're
a defense from the NHL against their
best offensive player or you're a golfer
and you have to make a nine-foot putt to
win a tournament right you better help
self-confidence in fact the separator
more often than not at the highest level
in sports is not they're a better
shooter or a better putter or throw the
ball a little bit faster because
everybody throws hard in the major
leagues nowadays it seems right that
separators their self-confidence it's
true and being a parent it's true and
being a businessperson it's true and
every year of our life the separator at
the top levels is self-confidence rule
number two take action I know for me
taking action really builds confidence
you know sometimes you almost have to
fake it until you make it if you just is
confident you start to feel confident
you think that that's percent you can't
if I say this all the time I can't teach
you how to steer a parked car right you
have to be in motion you have to be
moving and people wonder have I really
made a decision the real way we know if
you've made a decision to make a change
is that it's followed up with immediate
massive action as you said and that's
the thing I think there's a lot of
people invested in personal development
to make it more complicated than it
really is as if there's these secrets
you know whether it's the authors of the
books or mentors or whoever it is in
fact even you might be invested if if
you can make it yourself believe that
winning is complex because really
complexity is the enemy of execution
right but if you can make yourself think
it's complex then it's really not your
fault you haven't won yet because you're
missing something rather than it
probably being what it really is is that
you're unwilling or avoiding the work
you need to do to really go build your
company or build your field force or
build your body or build your life and
so it's being able to simplify things
and really know that there is no key to
really winning the key is the hard work
and keeping things as simple as you can
also if you want even more confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
it's free the link is in the description
below the minute you begin to get
external in your life worrying about
what other people think about you right
you vote you've lost all control you and
it and it never fills you up rule number
three alter your beliefs there's this
Governor on our lives and it is a
governor and it's a it's your identity
it's this internal it's what you think
you're worth it's what you think you
deserve and the problem for good people
see we all know someone right now in our
life or
we have who's not ethical who's not a
good person who's winning and you're
like I can't believe they're getting it
right why can't I I'm a good person I
treat people while I'm honest
here's a reason why by the way the
unethical person eventually karma you
reap what you sow comes home to roost
but if you're a good person this is so
important people understand this because
it took me a long time a good person in
any endeavor will only take from it what
they think they deserve what they think
they're worth in other words if there
was a pizza here you're a good person
you don't take all 12 pieces a good
person thinks there should be an
equitable distribution layer so I might
take seven or eight arm-wrestle you for
I don't know about a your mousse but but
long story short what is is that you a
good person will not take more from the
table of life than they think they're
worth or they think they deserve and so
you have this governor on your identity
so what happens is our it's like a
thermostat our lives get going we start
doing really well if we're a 75 degree
or and our life gets to 85 and 90
degrees unconsciously we go we don't
know we're doing it oh we start to cool
life back down to get it back to where
we're comfortable that reverse is also
true when things start to go really bad
and you're broke and you're struggling
you find a way to heat your life back up
to what you think you're worth and you
deserve so the way we alter our life is
sure we got alter our behavior and our
relationships and our circumstances but
the only way it's permanent is that we
alter that governor that thermostat and
we start to believe we're worth 85
degrees of life 95 degrees of life 110
degrees of life and there's ways we can
alter that how do we alter it a couple
different ways a one is what you just
said is that you put yourself in
circumstances that are demanding if you
pass what you think your capacity is and
when you succeed at them you build a new
water line you do you throw yourself out
there past where you're comfortable and
you do an 85 degrees behavior and you
knock it out of the park ago your brain
starts to believe it repetitiously when
you start doing that you build a new
line now you're 85 degrees that's number
one
the second way though is Association if
you're around people and whatever that
endeavor is if it's a sport you're in or
if it's a business or your faith or your
peace if you begin to associate with
people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heated up yeah so if
you're an athlete
for example you're a 70-degree athlete
and you start training all the time with
85 and 90 degrees your identity through
osmosis goes up if your person is trying
to improve their faith in their life or
their their personal piece about them
you all know this you've seen it when
you start to hang around people that are
a little bit more peaceful than you or
meditate a little bit more through that
association over time the thermostat
changes in that area and so it's both
behaving in certain way and then your
associations yeah I believe that and
rule number four the last one before a
very special bonus clip is stop caring
what other people think I would call
that trying to prove people wrong or
right about you is a cheap level of
motivation and it will wear out in other
words it's not and it's not the lack of
it it's just it's not the best type
people say well hey Tom Brady six round
draft pick I mean he's constantly trying
to prove them that they picked the wrong
guys I know Tommy a little bit and I can
tell you that motivates him but if you
think he's become the greatest football
player of all time because he's trying
to prove people from 20 years ago wrong
about where he was drafted you don't get
elite performance Tom Brady is where he
is because he sets standards for himself
and has massive goals and ambitions for
himself not to prove other people wrong
I promise you when he's sitting under
Center in the Super Bowl he's not going
I was a six round draft pick that's not
what moves him yeah and so I think it's
a low level motivation I do it too and
the sooner you drop it's it's a it's the
symptom of the same disease right so
proving your family wrong or right is
the symptom of the same disease which is
you are still obsessed with what other
people are thinking about you and not
doing things that make you happy that
enrich you to fulfill your soul and so
the irony about spending your life
worrying about what everybody else
thinks about you here's the irony is
that those people will never be thought
about after they're dead so they spend
their life obsessing with everyone
thinks about them only to die and have
no one ever remember them because people
that are so obsessed with what other
people think about them never really
ever fulfill their potential so once you
can drop that addiction whether it's
friends strangers or your parents and
you begin to do things that fulfill you
that make you happy yeah that change
other people's lives by your
contribution now you can be remembered
now you're your life that goes into
eternity even if it was a quiet life
right
got a special bonus clip from aired on
how to practice gratitude that I think
you could enjoy but before that
somewhere the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one whose opinion do you
need to stop caring about number two
what belief of yours do you need to
alter and number three what promise do
you need to keep to yourself I had a
really good friend of mine I went to
lunch and he said I don't know who this
guy is here in front of me and he goes
let me ask you a question honestly right
now what are you grateful for and at the
lunch I said Jack nothing brother
there's nothing good in my life right
now and I'm not exaggerating this to you
when I tell you this and this is a
factual story as I'm mouthing these
words two people walked in with an older
man both of them clearly were fighting
cancer somehow both had lost their hair
one of the ladies had a bonnet on and
they were barely moving in both walked
by our table and gave me the most warm
greeting the warmest smile as a stranger
and he goes that's pretty freaking
pathetic you can't find anything in your
life to be grateful for right now and on
the drive home I'm not kidding you I
started to stack gratitude I started to
take inventory because if you can find
things to be grateful for in that space
man as your life going to be rich when
there really are external things to be
grateful for
so my first mechanism out of that space
was honestly to stack the things I was
grateful for and I started reinforcing
it over and over and over again
and what happens is there's this
reticular activating system in our
brains right and all of a sudden because
that's the messaging I was giving myself
all of a sudden all these things start
to come into my awareness that I'm
grateful for I start to magnetize to
myself some people that I needed to find
into my life and that was the next layer
I started to see things to be grateful
for my health my fitness people who
loved me and what it did is it changed
my state when I stacked gratitude I
changed what I did in the morning and I
changed what I did in the evening and so
somehow by grabbing control of my
morning and by grabbing control of my
evening I got some measure of control
over the middle of my day I was an out
of control person back in those days
meaning this I woke up worried stressed
fearful and I immediately started
thinking about a bill
had to pay something that was wrong and
I'm in a state of reaction to begin
every sound talking within six minutes
of waking up six seconds most people
listening to this that's what they do I
said I got to grab control of my morning
and I set up routines in my morning
maybe they serve me maybe they didn't
but they were things I could deliver on
doing for myself and so not only did
that give me control over the day but I
started to stack my self-confidence to
if you want to learn from Tony Robbins
and how to create massive confidence
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
our strongest drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves
if your self definition is I'm a
situation where I'm kind of